[Music]
on Monday competitive eater Joey
Chestnut did you see this I heard about
it Joey Chestnut reclaimed his crown
when he won Nathan's Famous hot dog
eating contest check it out gotta get
that one down there we go with 69 final
second believable new record seven hot
dogs a minute which is impressive if
you're into speed eating okay now I'm
not that kind of guy mm-hmm I am more
impressed by endurance eating I think
that's the real skill Wow yeah and we
happen to have a nationally ranked food
marathoner on our staff it's our prop
master bill tall bill has been eating
the same hotdog for over 16 hours ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
over 16 hours even into it
yeah and he's he's really taking his
time how's it going there bill I can't
feel my legs
this is pretty incredible and do you
think I can do it that I think and I
think I think that this is exactly what
it is yeah what we just saw yeah that's
what it is what we're gonna do is we're
gonna move on from this for just a bit
it's harder to cut away from this
because it's so exciting right right Oh
settle down settle down but we are gonna
do huh there he is over there he's still
going
we are gonna step away for just a second
and talk about something more important
but then I assure you we will check back
okay bill okay cuz all right I know if
he can make it to the finish line okay
let's take a second and check back in
with our prop master bill tall thrilling
stuff he's been eating the same hotdog
for over 16 hours
[Applause]
how's it go in there bill I'm not sure
I'm gonna make it tell my wife I love
her bill you're uh you're not married
well then
[Applause]
[Music]
could marathoner built all everybody was
everybody come back mega Mawile
[Applause]
you